I was born in the rural western part of Kenya
I'm the youngest in my family, a family of 14
I'm from Cincinnati Ohio
Also my mother's children's book writer and
illustrator
and my dad's an architect so I was always surrounded
by a illustrations graphics
I've been teaching ballet for fifteen years and
we've been doing things naturally
I essentially came
came here too
focus on the indigenous women
of the border lands.
so I grew up in China
in Shenyang which is the center of Manchuria
which used to be the capital city of China
at the beginning of the Ching Dynasty. well I'm originally
from India
and
right after high school I went to medical
school in India
which was just sort of a natural progression
because my parents
are doctors, my sisters a doctor, so it was
sort of like the only profession that I knew
about
my interest is in
how different cultures and different religions
vary in their views on
different moral ethical issues such as the
use of force, conduct of war, conflict resolution
especially as the current wars that
we are in now there's a lot of complexities and
ambiguities
which I experienced while I was in the military and thought
maybe we can better prepare
soldiers on the ground and sailors and airmen
and I started doing a lot of research and
Harvard Divinity school and great both because
it addresses not just Judeo-Christian ethics
but
a whole range of religious ethics
it allowed me with the flexible
curriculum to the design my own course of interest
and study as I please the way I felt best
to shape what I wanted to do.
I didn’t really think about college
that much until it really just
came and then
at some point I guess I had to apply to college and so I
so I
was kind of stunned when I was accepted but
one of the first classes that I took, in fact one of the first things I did when I came here
we went to an interview for
a freshman seminar in
medieval books of ours
it was there that I first realized that aside
from
just my own interest in taking books
and forming them to be the way I wanted
0:02:15.819,0:02:18.569
there is an academic discipline where you
could do that
and so I found my way in a kind of cross over
between
art history and book history
I think I tried to
or found that out in a  really broader way
by taking
history and
and
history of the book and political philosophy
and tons of literature I really loved literature
and then a lot of art history
which has just been absolutely magnificent.
Actually, I had never heard of Harvard
until junior high school
I ever even know that I was even going to come to the US
when I was in high school I thought I was going to graduate and go
work for my dad in a firm  or go to a university,
a local university. But then when I was in junior high school
I started reading some Journals that my teacher would bring to school
I was seeing all these cutting edge research, most of them were done here at Harvard
and I said wow,
this is an amazing institution and I met
these Harvard alumns
and they say, yeah you are from this really tiny school
in Kenya
no one knows, and you should
definitely try applying to Harvard.
And I was just applying saying oh yeah
I have no
chance but luckily a got into Harvard
and I was really amazed.
One of the highlights I think
was in the spring of
'07
that divinity school
supported me in putting together the first
panel of
indigenous peoples speaking on their
spirituality
which it was the first time that Harvard had recognized
indigenous spirituality as a legitimate
region
so it was pretty monumental and historic and I realize
that this was more than just
you know I really needed to bring
my home, my heart to this community and I couldn't just, you know
be a Harvard student, I always needed to carry
home with. You know what I mean?
and to represent my peoples and my ancestors.
I had an epiphany  in class the other day
as a result of a grant application that
that I did for the final project for arts
and education
in which my initial
desire was to create
an outreach program that was centered on
ballet
and through
discussions in the arts and ed. program
about the various intrinsic values of all arts
for kids
it made me reflect on the true value of dance,
what dance does for children.
and the actual impact it has on kids because I've
always done it
because of what I see
in them and now with the readings that I've
been doing and the conversations I've been
having and the
classes I've been taking I can see
it really is valid and it really is a very
important thing for kids to,
for kids to be exposed to
actually Harvard was the only school I applied to.
and the same thing with music, Berklee was the only school I applied to
in some ways I was lucky, but at the same time
I was actually helping  a friend of mine
sort of figure out his application and
things like that and I sort of bumped into the public
school and then
felt like the public health care management and policy program
was really up my street
and so that sort of lead me to the Reynolds fellowship at the Kennedy school here
at Harvard
which really enabled me
the pursue the masters in public health
at the school of public health.
In China there are
six disciplines
to develop persons in the physical
and the
mental dimensions
Li: propriety
you have music
archery
charioting
history
mathematics
so basically
I think this has been exercised over
many thousands of years and there is a certain
wisdom to
the liberal arts education, and I just think
Harvard does a fantastic job in that
as a major in mathematics and physics
I was able to learn
classical music class western classical music
and
I was able to take some courses in economics
and which eventually got me interested in
going to
graduate school for a PHD in
finance and economics.
so I'm looking at further schooling,
the Kennedy school
the law school, applied to a couple fellowships
so we will see what happens, Harvard again, if they'll have me
this year I did
I did all of my research and that lead to
exhibit was really one of the nicest events that I've done here
and I was so moved by how many
people came I couldn't believe that all these
people who I really admire and care out
and
who really shaped my course here
but they all just came there because I sent them an email, and that was just overwhelming
I've had some really amazing amazing classes
that I've taken a very broad range
if you've gone through the education program
here if you've got get a master's at
Harvard it opens so many doors and I've
made so many valuable connections just in
my short time here.
a lot of my colleagues and friends they're
going into the Ministry you know to the pulpit
my ministry and
my medicine I think
are in the birthing rooms, as a midwife.
you know we see so many
priest, pastors, religious figures at weddings
and funerals but
they don't seem to be hanging out in the birthing
room so I feel that that's
the moment where
the angels are so I need to be there.
something that I would like to take away with me that I've got from Harvard
is the fact that
you can't live in your own island you have to cooperate and live with others
and team work
and that type of stuff
that has built me as an individual
If it's one word I think it's leadership
I think it's the expertise, the confidence
and it's the resources
to really lead
and to really  believe in what I do because
you know before this of course I had a very persuasive argument
in terms of music and medicine
because I'm a physician and I also have training in music therapy
but then you know having the knowledge and expertise
about strategy and
and sustainability and scalability and issues
like that I think it's it's really about leadership
that's what I'm really taking
out of Harvard
I wouldn't be as happy
or I wouldn't be able to achieve as much
without the help
from my professors from my friends
so I every time
when on I was able to achieve something
I always try to take a moment
to reflect on the fact that
this is not my achievement, it's the achievement
of all the people within my life
my circle.